oh God oh God I did not expect that that
just burned the hair in my nose
what do you do with this
cheese sorry that is cheese I thought it
was butter
[Music]
hey everybody this is pink this is snack
Wars UK versus the US on lad Bible here
we go
oh what do we got
is this Mickey D's
what is this
a mcplant burger oh they didn't make
this when I worked there
can you hear that I worked at McDonald's
look at all that
ew I can already tell you which one's
better what's this one
no I was driving through girl for a year
wow what's Greg's is a very famous okay
[Music]
okay good
um
sometimes I wish I meet
no offense Mickey D's but I'm going with
Greg's yeah yeah I don't even want that
it smells like plastic
okay so what we have here is a classic
beans on toast okay
what is the Hard Rock Cafe deal oh mac
and cheese we got one for the U.S
oh look at all these carbs
are you a mac and cheese fan ah yeah
no I don't know about this guys
oh God
no no I'm going back over here macaroni
and cheese for the win
foreign
pickle
tart and tangy flavor yeah and this is
American yeah so it's basically
oh see guess who's not on Tic Tac tick
tick tock tick tock
I might be the last man standing
okay
oh God oh God I did not expect that that
just burned the hair in my nose
what do you do with this
cheese I thought it was butter
I mean it's not though I just wasn't
ready
so just a little bit
hello my little friend
this is by choice people do this yeah
okay
I mean it's not bad
yeah yeah
now this I would put in a martini
for sure
[Music]
oh my God
I'm so salty
this is as salty as my husband
this is a bit much okay it's
um
I um I would really prefer not to eat
either but I would use this sauce for a
martini but I do like this cheese what
kind of cheese is it it's just very
standard marked cheddar
I'm going with the cheese
so who is that uh we're gonna go with
you guys the UK
oh
oh you guys screwed up now
these are my favorite
spicy Cheetos oh God
monster Munch sounds interesting Flamin
Hot okay
look at the color it's like nuclear lava
it really is
if I could live inside a bag of Cheetos
I would
[Music]
um
okay that's got a kick
yep that's that's kicky these are cute
yeah
they look like they look like clown
hands
what do you think they look like well
they're meant to be a big
foot oh cute oh yeah I see the toe
it's called a shrimp job
these aren't as spicy I don't know
they're good I would eat these
but I love Cheetos okay okay it's a tie
this is gonna be interesting because
it's gonna matter which wine you chose
we've got Dark Horse Cabernet
that just says California on it
splurge
on tonic wine
what does that even mean made by this
see how look this is 43.
made by the benek Dean Bennett Dean
monks uh buckfast Abby Devin okay this
is interesting but tonic wine what does
that even mean
wow that color is quite something oh God
did you hear about the monks that got
arrested for the meth
yeah they were all on meth I was like
shut up that's my favorite headline I've
ever read
they were all just messing around
How would how do you sit and meditate on
meth do monks meditate is that a
different thing am I like no they
meditate right pray how do you pray on
meth I Dear God
okay tonic wine oh if I throw up on TV
it smells bad does it
I imagine
tastes like Robitussin
um NyQuil Robitussin oh yeah cough
medicine
oh God
it smells like bleach
[Music]
foreign
I think they're both pretty bad
maybe this one's a tie oh yeah
I make wine and it doesn't taste like
that okay you know when you see a bottle
of wine that just says California yes
you might be in trouble okay
Ty okay side all right oh
what are you toxic waste oh my daughter
would love this green sour candy yeah
this has to be the American yeah yeah
licorice oh I don't like licorice
that means we might win
oh
[Music]
licorice is awful
do people like licorice
no one right no one who you do yeah
would you like to participate in this
challenge
[Music]
it's like Pepto-Bismol got mad wow
um
[Laughter]
I'm going with toxic waste it's a great
great name yeah
um
can I have the rest of these I want to
take these home to my daughter
oh my God that's really sour though yeah
oh yeah
for this game it was a draw yay
I think
[Music]
what the
yo holy no oh my God
oh my God oh my God